machine écoutez les gars quel est le nom
du chanteur de Qin Machine David boy Tony
sales han sales in reves Gabriel n'était pas
dans machine né à Berlin en 1977 nous avons
commencé à travailler ensemble en 1977 nous en avons
fait où nous avons fait un album
avec Iggy  Pop et nous travaillions en
studio ou peut-être cinq semaines et nous avons fait
que nos albums durent toute la vie,
puis peu de temps après, l'album est
sorti et nous sommes partis sur la route. J'ai un
rendez-vous chez le dentiste jeudi prochain, je
pense que nous allons  être fait d'ici là et ensuite
nous serons avec vous dans une seconde c'était un
rappeur comme moi je ne vais pas perdre mon emploi
si vous parlez ensemble d'accord désolé David
tu aurais pu mettre fin à ta vie de
superstars Frank Sinatra Jim Morrison
pourquoi  tu choisis de retourner dans l'
underground je voulais être présentateur télé
mais je n'avais juste pas ce qu'il
faut tu dis que ce n'est
plus rentable d'être un monstre je sais mais il
a un super visage pour la radio
ouais tu penses vraiment  qu'une certaine
machine de rencontres sera aussi célèbre qu'un
David Bowie
peut-être Maurice Chevalier, voyons d'accord
sur la machine à capacités,
c'est très bien